hello everybody i am uh here with father
andrew damick who doesn't need much of
an introduction but for those who don't
know he is uh he is a head of ancient
faith publishing content and he just
published a new book called arise oh god
the gospel of christ defeat of demons
sins and death and i just finished the
book it's a very interesting and
succinct introduction to all the amazing
stuff that uh that he's been talking
about with father stephen on the lord of
lord of spirits podcast and just kind of
introducing people to a a more cosmic
and a more story version of the
salvation that christ brings and so i'm
really happy to be able to uh to talk
about that with him right now
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
thank you very much for having me on
jonathan it's
it's always a joy to be with you
so tell us a little bit about the kind
of the impetus for writing this new book
of yours
right so
i i i most of my writing comes from a
sense of frustration actually
which i don't know if that's the best
way to do it but it's it's what i've got
and my frustration in this particular
case was that i wanted a book
that summarized the gospel
from a truly orthodox christian point of
view
that i could use for uh evangelistic and
catechetical purposes and just trying to
relate what the orthodox christian faith
is to people
you know for whatever reason they might
be interested in it and um
there as far as i know at least in
english there there isn't such a book um
that does that
and um so
i had the idea of um particularly
framing it in terms of a lot of the
things that we talk about in the lord of
the spirits podcast because
not just to kind of you know promote the
podcast or whatever but because
that's what i actually believe the
gospel is about
right and so
you know the the basic frame is that
there is a cosmic war on
and we are caught up in the midst of it
we're kind of in the crossfire
and uh the gospel is what happens
to us really in response to that war
it's what god does in the midst of that
war that has something to do with us as
human beings and um so so that's that's
the the genesis behind the book um i'm
very very interested in
um
an evangelistic work and in you know
education and so forth and so i'm always
looking for new ways to uh convey this
kind of thing to people
yeah one of the great parts of the book
let's say especially in in let's say
protestant
catholic north america especially kind
of protestant culture in north america
this idea that the gospel is you know
this how you're going to be saved
basically it's framed as what the
individual it's a frame that's kind of
the let's say the advantage to the
individual and how you're going to go to
heaven and you need to believe these
things and kind of have faith in a broad
sense and this atonement this kind of
substitutionary version of of christ's
sacrifice and that way you go to heaven
but you present something which is far
more cosmic and is more about the gospel
being this proclamation of what's
happening right this is what's happening
in the cosmos now how are you going to
participate in this transformation
right yeah you know i i was raised as
the son of evangelical protestant
missionaries and so
uh what is the gospel how do you
communicate the gospel that's was on my
mind from a very very early age
and one of the things that i found is
the way that most people in the
english-speaking world think of what the
gospel is
is they think it's about what christ can
do for them
right and and i mean i could i could
express that in very cynical terms like
you know how can jesus make my life
better or or or you know much better
terms like okay the gospel is about how
you are saved from from hell how you are
saved from
from sin and death you know and um while
it's true that the gospel is related to
those things
um
if we put it in those terms right that
it's essentially about something
that that uh fixes a problem in my life
let's say
um if if that's what i understand the
gospel is then that means that
communicating the gospel to people is
essentially a kind of sales pitch
right because you know if someone's
selling something to you they come to
you and say okay you have a problem or
you have a lack in your life you know
that there's something there's a problem
that you need to be fixed and i
i i have the answer
i i'm here to give this to you right and
you know so so again looking at it not
cynically saying well i'm here to give
you the answer for free you know you
just have to get on board with whatever
version of get on board
that means right um but looking at it
cynically it comes across as a kind of
sales pitch
and um a lot of times especially people
who are not
not believers in christianity
they experience it that way
and uh they take it very cynically like
well you just want me to join your thing
so you can get money out of me or you
just want me to join your your thing
because
you know you you want to just you know
it's affirming for you of how many
converts you can make or that kind of
thing and you know
that's the problem with understanding
the gospel as being how i get saved
because then it's completely about
what is the problem of the person in
front of me how can i sort of sell them
you know my solution
i mean i i might really believe in it
and not be profiting from it in any way
but still it's essentially a kind of
sales pitch you have a problem i have
the solution
right
whereas um
the gospel as it's expressed in the
bible
is not that
there is no point in which any apostle
ever comes up to someone says let me
tell you about what jesus can do for
your life
like there's no point in which they say
you look you have a problem and i have
the solution to your problem
like that's that never happens in
scripture
right
what happens is when the gospel begins
being preached
they pick this word for it
uh evangelion is the greek word right
which
most the time you see that word
explicated by people that say it means
good news
and that is literally what the word
means if you pull it apart
etymologically good and news right
but in the ancient world that's not how
the word was used
the word was actually used in the
ancient world to refer to something that
was about to happen
the announcement of something that was
happening
and that really you didn't have much
choice
about
actually it was something that was about
to happen to you in fact
right um and i'll explain why i'm not a
calvinist in just a second but uh
it was about like the idea of a victory
of an emperor the victory or the emperor
is coming everybody be ready this is
this is it isn't a way for them the way
they were presenting was it's good news
it's like you know caesar has vanquished
our foes you know now we will have this
these riches will have this and
he's accumulating glory for rome and so
there's this kind of sense of this uh
this the the this this vanquishing of
foes and this kind of heroic gesture
yeah and the the evangelion they usually
expressed in plural was when a herald
would ride into the city and he would
open up his scroll or whatever and say
three things
this is the lord whom i serve let's say
he serves caesar you know augustus
whoever this is who he is
uh you know maybe listing off all his
amazing titles this is what he's
accomplished listing off all of his
victories in battle
and you know and he's bringing this
along with him and now this is what he
expects of all of you yeah right he's
coming to take over the city
and so you can either get on board with
his rule
or you can be put outside the rule which
in the roman world largely meant that
you were going to be slaughtered uh you
know
the idea of moving somewhere else to
find a new government just was not a
thing
yeah right and so when you know when the
apostles choose this word evangelion
saying by the way this is the gospel
they are saying the same thing
they are identifying who their lord is
jesus christ they're saying what he's
done he's defeated his enemies and
they're saying what he expects of you
uh if you know if you're going to be
part of his kingdom part of his rule
yeah right and so that's what the gospel
is it's actually a declaration of
victory
really on an offer no exactly it can
help you understand a lot even of the
way that the orthodox represent
for example the crucifixion we always
have nica in the crucifixion in the
sense that there is this in the story of
christ there is this almost kind of
incomprehensible joining of opposites in
which his death vanquishes death in
which you know his humiliation turns
into glory but it is nonetheless
participating in the most surprising way
in this idea of the king who takes his
throne of the emperor who vanquishes not
just his enemies but basically the enemy
of all which is death itself
right yeah you know
there's a lot of people who have heard
of this model they call it christus
victor right the idea that christ is
victorious
and um which is good right but sometimes
the the circle is not extended out very
far
it's only extended into christ is
victorious over the problems of my life
right um so i mean that that is true but
it's really a narrow narrow
understanding
um we have to understand that like i
said there was a war you know if it's if
it's an announcement a victory over
enemies then you have to know who those
enemies are
and people in the ancient world who were
living in under idolatry
they had an actual day-to-day experience
of interacting with demonic beings
and in many cases relying on them or
thinking they can rely on them
right so so it's it's a victory not just
over sort of metaphysical problems or a
victory over
the problems of my life it's a victory
over actual spiritual enemies who are
being defeated actual fallen angels and
actual demonized uh human souls who have
participated with those fallen angels
right so so we're being rescued not just
from a kind of internal problem we're
actually being rescued rescued from the
domination of dark powers yeah and it i
mean there is an analogy between the two
that is it like he's what we're saying
it doesn't mean that christ won't if you
participate in his life you participated
in the sacraments if you live the life
that christ
uh directed for us like that you won't
solve your problems you will solve your
problems but that's not that's not the
limit of what christ does right right
the connection between
these
principalities which have been ruling
over the world which have kind of led
the world into degeneracy and into
violence into all these these kind of
dark places uh that these are real and
that christ defeated them both in you
that is the passion that has a cosmic
virgin in these demons but then also in
the world we are we've yet to see it
fully realized but we have these
burgeoning images of that in the saints
in the in the communion of saints and in
the communion that we all participate in
the church itself right right exactly
you know that there's there's a macro
and a micro level to all of this and the
reason why that's important right is not
just so that we have the big picture
it actually affects the way people live
their lives if they understand that
they're part of something bigger
you know i'll just give you a really
good example a very small example but
one that actually affects people all the
time so as a priest you know i hear
confessions and a lot of times people
talk about the the evil thoughts that
they have and sometimes where they act
on those evil thoughts i mean this is an
experience we all have yeah right and
most of the time they will say something
like i don't know what's wrong with me
or i can't make those thoughts go away
right or something like that you know is
is is am i just not really a christian
or you know something like that right so
there's this this sense of a closed
system that they're experiencing
and they they uh you know because
for their from their point of view
christianity is about fixing what's
going on in that closed system
but if you understand that christ's
defeat of demons his defeat of cosmic
enemies of god right that that that you
know mediates all the way down to us on
our individual level then you'll begin
to understand that evil thoughts
actually come from outside
and so the fact that you keep having an
evil thought doesn't mean that you have
a fatal flaw
it means that the enemy continues to
attack you
right that the enemies of god are not
me or
people doing bad things in the world the
enemies of god are actual spiritual
beings right and so it you know if we
reduce the gospel to how can god solve
my problems
uh even understood in the best possible
way then then the temptation to despair
is very easy
right uh and you know it's interesting
if you read especially the writings of
some of the modern uh holy elders of the
orthodox church they talk about demons
all the time
all the time you know it it's constant
because they understand very clearly
that the the intrusive evil thoughts
that we have
are temptations coming from outside
right and the fact that we keep having
them doesn't mean
i'm
you know a spiritual loser
right
it just means that the enemy continues
to shoot his darts at me yeah well you
read the story of saints who you know
after 30 years of fasting and doing all
they're still struggling they sell these
thoughts to kind of intrude on them and
sometimes like you said it's true that
even when i read those texts i am
tempted to despair because i'm thinking
okay man this like i'm not even you know
like a tent on the road of this amazing
aesthetic but but it's like it seems
like this
this problem is something that is that
is going to kind of uh follow us you
know until we're fully glorified let's
say
it's true i mean like there's that
beautiful amazing icon of saint anthony
in the desert being attacked by demons
like physically attacked by demons and
here's a man who is super advanced
spiritually right and yet he's
experiencing these attacks and i'm sure
he didn't say unless some demon
whispered this idea to him he didn't say
to himself i guess i just have a fatal
flaw
you know exactly
right you know and and you know part so
part of what the book does is it sets up
the battlefield like why is it that this
we are having this experience of demonic
attack you know it's because
of the the sort of the three problems of
mankind that mankind experiences right
so the introduction initially of of
death right which that comes through the
influence of a demon talking to eve and
then adam gets on board with that and
then the introduction of sin which comes
as a result of demonic attack on cain
because death kind of opened the door
for sin to be released into the world as
this evil influence and then and then
eventually especially after the tower of
babel you get the domination of the
nations kind of by direct rule of demons
right and so
yeah this is something which people
don't know a lot about because it
doesn't say that in the story of the
tower of babel says it later i think
it's in deuteronomy uh where the idea
that god said upon the world these
angels that we're supposed to manage
that were kind of
that were these principalities that were
supposed to manage the world it also
helps us in our like both you and i we
we have this argument against monotheism
in the
silly sense like in the simplistic sense
like there's just god no god functions
through all these principalities and
intelligences that come all the way down
to us
um but that at the tower babel these
principalities were set upon the world
and then they started to
accept worship and so there's a
fragmentation and the fragmentation that
we see
almost in the story of the tower of
babel seems to reflect that
fragmentation itself where people
started to just worship their own thing
or have their incomprehensible language
that was self-contained and so they they
worship these these demons um and so
this this version the book really does
take you on the cosmic story very kind
of nice and tight
version of this cosmic story of the fall
of the relationship between these cosmic
intelligences and the individual how we
move all the way into christ that's kind
of solving the puzzle and so like i said
at the beginning it's for people that
like a lot of people when i tell them go
into lord of spirits they look at the
amount of podcasts and like the
three-hour podcast one after the other
and they think
oh my you know and even even father
stephen's book really jim the apostle
which is great but it's a little like
for some people it might be a little
much to chew on at the outset so your
book really is a very nice type uh
narrative version of this whole kind of
cosmic story yeah yeah like one of the
things that some people have said so
i've got a copy of it right here there
you go some people have said they're
like
this book is really small yes uh and
it's i think it's about like 26 or 7 000
words total
um
but that's actually super deliberate
because it's focused specifically on
what is the gospel
and you know it starts out by saying
like what's not the gospel right so it's
not the offer it's not a sales pitch now
people do have a choice to get on board
when caesar rides into town you can
either get on board with caesar or you
can resist him and then suffer the
consequences of that right so you do
have a choice again i'm not a calvinist
uh but then i explain also like
why wha what's the need for a gospel
right so i talked about you know the
these three problems of mankind that all
have to do with demons
death sin and direct domination by
demons and then i flip i show i flip it
then and so
okay so here's the announcement here's
who christ is here's what he
accomplished which
he fixed those three problems in
essentially the reverse order
so he begins by
um
you know he releases us from domination
by demons by exorcism
he releases us from slavery to sin by
forgiveness
and then he
destroys the power of death by
resurrecting
right and uh and then and then having
shown what the announcement to the
gospel is then i ask the question well
how do you how do you respond
right so you see this in the bible all
the times someone an apostle preaches
the gospel to someone and then and then
they say
what must i do to be saved
right they don't they don't say oh you
just told me what i have to do to be
saved now what must i do to be saved
right because if if the gospel was what
must i do to be saved then why would
they say that or they ask that exactly
yeah it's the announcement oh wait
someone's coming he's coming to judge
the living and the dead
what do i have to do to get on board
with this right and then and then and
then you know very succinctly i also
then talk about what happens when you do
get on board with it
you know how is
how does this actually change
you and your your destiny and and what
does that have to do with so if demons
are
connected with all of our problems then
actually
angels are connected with all the
solutions yeah as as a matter of fact
and we then become like them right yeah
that's something which i think
i think you really illuminated for so
many people the idea that in
understanding the divine counsel and
understanding god sitting in his divine
counsel as you know all these managing
principalities that that's that kind of
sit over the cosmos with god as their
king or god as the infinite source of
these these smaller powers then all of a
sudden the idea of becoming like gods or
or you know or
you know becoming like angels is not
just a little metaphor that we can kind
of understand as becoming more spiritual
or something like that but it is really
this idea of this
this possibility of human beings
becoming real principalities in the
world and becoming managers and pillars
by which reality actually man you know
shows itself and little examples of that
of course are in the idea of patron
saints for different aspects of reality
but also patrons of of places and
patrons of churches patrons of
communities as this this little seed or
this burgeoning image of how we will
ultimately reign with christ and and
become like angels yeah right you know
most orthodox people and a lot of other
people who have studied um
early christianity they probably know
this phrase from saint athanasius the
great in on the incarnation where he
says uh and you could translate this
several different ways but god became
human that man might become divine or
sometimes god became man that man might
become god with a small g or a big g
depending although in ancient greek you
don't have it's just all big big
uh
actually it's a big theta it's not a g
um you know um but what's interesting so
then a lot of people see that like okay
wow so you know
through the incarnation of christ if we
participate in that we can become like
god we become divine in some sense right
um what's really fascinating is uh saint
athanasius actually puts all of this in
the framework of adoption
adoption as sons
right and and and again a lot of times
people then they'll see that and say oh
we're the children of god but
you actually have to plug in that phrase
sons of god
into an existing framework in scripture
right which that phrase sons of god
actually refers to a very high rank of
angels
so you know christ himself mentions this
in luke 20 36 which when i was an
evangelical i don't think i ever heard a
sermon about this verse but christ says
that the sons of the resurrection
becomes sons of god and equal to the
angels you go look it up yourself it's
luke 20 36 you know so so he says that
those who are in christ those who who
are who you know rise in christ and rise
to life everlasting they are sons of god
again that's a rank of angels and he
says to kind of bear down on the idea
equal to the angels
which means that this process of theosis
is very intimately connected with our
angelology yeah right now we don't
become
we don't take on angel nature
i don't you know we can't do that we
remain human but we become equal to the
angels
right which means that we then we begin
to do their works
because their works are to do the works
of god and so if we do the works of god
then we are functioning the way that the
angels do and as you said you know we
see this in in the idea of patron saints
who they function exactly like angels i
mean look at what saints do in the
history of the church they do all the
things that angels do in scripture
they appear to people they take care of
people they they hear their pleas and
with god's power not their own with
god's power they they help them uh you
know they they protect them they do
battle against uh evil spiritual beings
um they they guide people into into
knowledge of god like all of these
things are angelic functions you know
they bear messages from god
these are all things that the saints do
so they are becoming the sons of god
yeah right yeah and so and this kind of
narrative more cosmological version of
the transformation of the person
in no way has to stand in competition or
go against the more mystical
transformation that we see in the the
field khalia and the notion of this kind
of transformation of the person you know
being free from the sins you know
becoming more in the image of god in a
in in a proper sense that is really
being transformed as a being into light
into you know being united with this
uncreated light that this kind of more
mystical vision which in some way has
been more popular maybe in the in the
19th 20th century because of
just because we're materialists and we
struggle with the more mythological
image of that that no we need those two
versions of it one which is almost like
a more technical or more
uh theological description of the
transformation of the person and the
other one which is more of this kind of
participation in a cosmic story which is
there in scripture the whole time and
moves into the eschaton you know and the
images of of the last judgment and all
these wonderful images that we see you
know in in in the i like iconography
that this is part of what this
transformation
reveals to us let's say right yeah that
you know
those those visions are completely
integrated within orthodox tradition and
in the scriptures
the the reason why we tend to
disintegrate them
is because of individualism because of
of modernism and individualisms right so
you know
theosis becomes about my journey in
christ you know like which is like it's
not wrong but it's super incomplete and
actually can distort
what we're doing right and you know this
is this is everywhere for instance in uh
orthodox hypnography like there's
there's one hymn that i i heard for
years and years which talked about you
know christ going after the lost sheep
and then adding it to the heavenly hosts
yeah wow like literally it says that he
goes after the lost sheep and then makes
it one of the you know part of the
angelic coasts and i heard that's that's
him for years and i i i just let it kind
of fly by and until i really realized
like wait this is what sons of god means
that we become part of the hosts of
heaven
then now i mean this stuff is now
popping everywhere yeah
i was thinking
little dots of light are starting to
connect into a pattern right right and
and and honestly it's very uh inspiring
and and exciting you know it's not just
okay i'm on the sort of solitary journey
to greatness
um but rather i'm i you know by god's
grace i'm headed deeper and deeper into
this
this vast host of of uh uh divine beings
yeah right and theologically we we
understand it more easily right in the
sense that as we kind of rise towards
god's our prayers and our love of others
is kind of bringing others into god with
us we kind of understand it when we say
it abstractly but when we really
understand it cosmologically then it
actually appears like you said as patron
saints who appear to people who who make
who do miracles who you know who so it
it's not just a it's not just a like an
abstract thing it's something which
actually uh let's say binds communities
together with with visions and
transformations and miracles and all
this stuff at the same time yeah yeah
there are so many kind of apologetical
problems that we create by accepting
individualism
you know if we can set that aside and
and recover this cosmic sort of mythic
understanding of what's going on in
scripture then all of these things kind
of fall into place
much more easily like if you understand
who the sons of god are then you kind of
don't really need to give an apologetic
for the intercession of the saints
because it's already there or like
someone would say well why do you have
saints you know i see angels like well
actually this the angels are the
original saints
like the word is being used for them in
scripture the holy ones of god saints
and holy ones are literally just
different english you know expressions
from two different parts of our
inheritance that mean exactly the same
thing yeah you know that's our angels
are the original saints yeah and we're
just saying that people are being added
into that and it's such a beautiful
image of this movement you know into the
fall and then into the the new jerusalem
for example as this this glorification
in christ of man all of this it just
makes so much sense once you see the
grand story of scripture that this will
be part of the the transformation and so
i wanted to
as we're talking about this kind of
mythical understanding of christianity
something we're both very excited about
i wanted to ask you a little bit about
something else that you're working on i
know maybe some people don't know that
father andrew is actually now in the
universe despite all the crazy things
that he's doing all the podcasts all the
books managing ancient faith content
he's also back in school uh studying i
think it's is it anglo-saxon northern
mythology exactly what are you studying
so okay so i'm studying at signum
university which is a fully online
master's degree program
and um the degree is language and
literature and i have two concentrations
within that so on the one hand there's a
concentration that's called
uh classical literature or something
like that but i'm basically steering it
towards mythology
right and then the other concentration
is tolkien studies and the cool thing is
there's a lot of overlap between those
two
and
right so it's it's i'm taking one class
a semester so that's three classes a
year uh the first class i took was
called
tolkien and tradition and it's literally
these two things together looking at
mythological sources alongside what
tolkien did with some of them
um and then this the second class i took
was introduction to old english so just
straight
you know learning a language and
translating and stuff and now i'm doing
beowulf in old english and so we're
translating about 300 lines of beowulf a
week which is super labor-intensive
um
i mean it's it's a little crazy yeah
but
but it's you know
beowulf is interesting because i think a
lot of times especially before tolkien
started getting hold of it and really
talking about it publicly in the middle
of the 20th century um a lot of a lot of
people looked at beowulf as just being
sort of a monster story you know i like
and well you know amongst our various
pieces of mythology this is not really
the best of them you know beowulf
doesn't go on to found some great
civilization or something like this uh
tolkien complains about this in an essay
that he wrote called beowulf the
monsters and the critics
um but but beowulf is indeed a monster
story but the whole point of it actually
is this this uh collision between a
christian world
and a world that frankly is about
monsters and dealing with monsters so
like beowulf is this
sort of demonic
giant-ish
you know being who lives in a kind of
grotto
uh underneath a lake in the mountains in
this sort of bog area
right and uh you know he has this he
hates
the the festivity and the the i mean
grendel i was like you you're not babe
with himself that's it
yeah
did i say bail
it's fine i just don't want to give you
right i kind of got
grendel is the monster yeah yeah beowulf
is the hero
um but you know and it's interesting
like just to give you
the interesting thing one of the
interesting things about beowulf is it's
set within a christianity that
understands this mythic unders mythic
view of the world and and like there
isn't another one to even compare it to
like this is simply the world they live
in to give you one little example
so beowulf kills grendel first by
ripping his arm off yeah uh and then and
then you know grendel
you know runs away and and dies down in
his cave uh but then his mother comes
and begins to
uh to do the same evil to the high hall
that that her son had been doing as kind
of her revenge for him so beowulf has to
go down and deal with the mother as well
when he goes down there
he finds
all these weapons down in the cave and
um and it doesn't say this in there but
you know again this is a kind of bog
monster so there is this suggestion if
you know something about bog sacrifices
that perhaps these are things that had
been shoved down in there by pagans who
were making offerings to these demonic
beings
now this is not written in the poem but
but that is part of what this world
includes yeah right so beowulf finds all
these weapons down there and he gets the
sword this mighty sword and he uses it
to slay grendel's mother and then he
while he's at it he decides to cut the
head off of grendel who's already dead
and then the the blade melts away
because of the sort of the toxicity of
the blood of these monsters but then on
the hilt
there's some kind of depiction or
writing there about
the giants and their war with god and
about how god sent a flood to deal with
the giants
so like this this this uh conflict the
giganto maki right the war against
giants is embedded into the story with
this short little reference that
everyone who listens to the poem in the
8th century is going to know yeah
right this this is there and there's
there's there's stuff like this all
throughout yeah i think grendel is even
he's even suggested or it's presented
that grando is a kind of descendant of
kane oh yeah that he's the descendant of
kane and so i i remember reading i
remember reading scholars talking about
bagels saying how all of this was just a
kind of cheap add-on to to the story you
know like these christian references
were just kind of added on to make it
acceptable to christian audience but i
think it's those scholars that didn't
understand just how
integrated this vision of the world
these this this idea of the monstrous
races and the giants and how it that's
actually really part of the of the
christian story from the beginning right
you know you've been doing uh you've had
some videos with richard rowland talking
about this question of universal history
and um
the truth is is that
pretty much every ancient mythology
has a number of elements to it that are
that that they all share right so like a
great example is almost all of them have
some kind of flood story yeah and a lot
of people know that oh like there's all
you know maybe there was some kind of
big flood you know and so
they all talk about this but a lot of
people don't realize is that connected
with the flood story is usually also a
story of giganto maki a war against
giants
um it's it's
it's in almost every mythology
that's out there right you know even not
just european ones either
you get it you know even in native
american stuff there's
giants and then a flood comes and wipes
out the giants right this this happens
over and over again um you know in norse
mythology
when odin and his brothers decide to
kill the big sort of primordial giant
emir
uh
his his toe begins bleeding and the the
blood floods the entire earth and kills
mostly
giants you know like it this is this is
everywhere or you know in in the epic
gilgamesh you know and kedu is basically
like noah i mean there's a noah figure
in the norse story too although weirdly
noah is a giant in the norse version um
and uh you know like this kind of thing
is everywhere and so like the reason
that i'm studying mythology occasionally
i get people asking me like why are you
studying all this pagan literature
you know
uh
why would you want to read that right
and
number one people should understand
actually that most pagan literature that
we have
did not come directly from pagans
almost all of it
came through
christian scribes yeah exactly who
preserved it and copied i mean
you know making books before the advent
of printing was a super slow and
expensive process
and
uh christians for centuries upon
centuries decided to spend a lot of
their resources on retaining
pagan literature
yeah right and and it's not because they
were syncretists
it's because they saw this literature as
representing something true about their
world that they were part of now you
know uh they weren't saying you know you
should just simply accept everything
that's in here and like go ahead and
worship these gods and you know whatever
they're not saying that uh but rather
like so saint bazel the great actually
has this text called uh it's usually
called something like um
an address on the uses of greek
literature to young men or something
like that so he's talking about
education and he actually says the crazy
wild thing that you should read and
master homer before you ever read the
bible he actually says now i do not
teach that
uh you know
but he actually says this in the fourth
century
why so why would he say that
i think part of it is that
um
the scripture is so much responding to
what's happening in paganism
that we have to understand that
in order to understand the scripture
correctly yeah right now in in basil's
time paganism was really on its way out
there were still some pockets of it in
the roman empire but not too many
right by the time you get to the late
fourth century
um but so it's not like basil is saying
like you know we need to fight against
those pagans right he's not really
saying that i mean there are pagans
around but not a lot
um but he is saying that this body of
knowledge this body of story is part of
our story yeah right and you get for
instance like there's a lot of ways that
that gets sort of dealt with
um
you know
one of my favorite examples is comes
from i think a 13th century church in
norway
where
if you were to walk up to the front of
the church you know to the front doors
you would see these beautiful wooden
carvings on either side of the door that
clearly are depicting scenes from a
story
well it's the story of sigurd killing
the dragon fafnir
which is a story from norse mythology
yeah
right
and you're like well what's going on
here and i've had people suggest me oh
they're trying to sort of trick pagans
to come in and like i'm like well how
stupid are pagans seriously like
there's a cross up on top of this church
you know like they're not that and like
as soon as they get through the door
they're gonna see jesus everywhere it's
not like they're gonna be like oh well i
came here thinking i was gonna go ahead
and worship thor but you know i might as
well stay for jesus like that's not
what's going on rather these are
christians who are saying this is in a
sense part of our story
you know and especially on the outer
door it's like it's it's almost
in the way that saint basil said you
almost have to kind of have these
stories this network of stories before
you enter into the church but just like
we have in the narthex and many
monasteries you know the greek
philosophers and and this kind of idea
that the pre-christian world has
something
something bubbling in it which can then
be kind of pointed uh pointed towards
christ and right now it seems that like
when i when i heard that you were
studying mythology you know for me it
made so much sense because
as we kind of in a way not knowing these
ancient stories and not knowing
mythology was a leisure of a christian
world like it was the leisure of a of a
world that was so fully christian that
we could almost forget the cosmic story
around which in which christianity uh
was born but now in this as the
christianity is kind of evacuating
public space as it's fragmenting into
all this this kind of nonsense then all
of a sudden the relevance of these
ancient stories and of the pagan stories
become
important again in my opinion because we
need to be able to kind of represent in
the secular world this cosmic vision and
how all these stories ultimately do
point to christ because people are
tempted by them people and all these
neil pagans and all these people looking
at in other cultures and looking at
buddhist stories and vedantic stories
and you know all these other myths and
if as christians we're not able to see
the bubbling in those stories the kind
of kind of frothing that is pointing
towards christ and we're missing an
opportunity to uh to kind of find the
lights in the darkness let's say yeah
yeah one of the things i earnestly
believe is that demons are coming back
oh yeah now i i don't think that they
went anywhere
right you know they haven't they haven't
they have not actually all been cast
into the abyss although fortunately for
us most of them have
but there are still enough
to cause massive problems
and they cause bigger problems when we
engage with them
in a cooperative way
and i think that as you as you said you
know as christianity continues to recede
from public life
that more and more people are
cooperating with demonic powers and so i
think it's especially important that we
understand
exactly who those demonic powers are and
what they do and that is also part of
why i'm reading mythology is you know
it's it's not necessarily that there is
a demon called uh thor
who who does thor things and and i need
to find him and point him out or
whatever
but rather if i understand the stories
about thor then i can see
interactions that people actually are
having with demons in the ancient world
because you know like we have this idea
that pagans made up stories of gods in
order to explain natural phenomena they
didn't understand but that is never the
way they said it yeah right that is that
is we're imposing that narrative on top
of them when we say that they all talked
about actually meeting spiritual beings
and interacting with them so now we can
decide okay i don't believe you i don't
believe you every single culture or
throughout the history of the world for
thousands of years i don't believe that
any of you actually had these
experiences yeah or maybe but i think
it's harder to it's harder to justify
that right now with the return of
psychedelics and all these it's getting
harder and harder getting involved in in
these
these kind of returning to to
hallucinogens than having
experiences which are objective across
individuals you realize that okay
no no there's something going on right
now in the world there's some kind of
there are these cracks that are forming
and there's there are these things
seeping in and the and we find a
relationship between the enochian story
of downfall with the the turn to magic
and technology into hybrids into chimera
and we can see the very same obsessions
that are popping up right now and it's
and the fact that it's actually related
to people
taking these substances and then
encountering these beings it's like
nah
i think it's harder even for atheists
and materials to argue with what's going
on right and you know in the ancient
world um taking substances in order to
directly connect with your gods was
something that was totally normal yeah
so like some of my ancient baltic
ancestors for instance uh i don't know
if they had access to psychedelics or
not but there was actually a saying that
unless you drink enough beer that god
can't hear you
right so there's this notion that
drunkenness was kind of required
for prayer of a certain kind
right and you know the other way that
ancient people actually directly
interacted with gods was by offering
sacrifices to them and eating them
um and there are people now doing that
again right there food being offered in
front of idols of gods and people are
eating them so that actually puts you
directly into communion with that god
it's it's it's the eucharist it's the
pagan eucharist essentially yeah right
you know the reason why the eucharist
works is the same reason why that works
uh but the big difference is who you're
doing it with
are you doing it with the god who made
you and loves you and has sacrificed
himself for you or are you doing it with
this lesser spiritual being who actually
just wants to drag you down into the
abyss with him yeah and he's going to
make all kinds of false promises to you
along the way yeah and there's even it
almost seems like there's even
like the way that it's happening now the
way it's manifesting itself and kind of
these new age movements and new pagan
movements it's almost even more chaotic
than what you see in like a regular
pagan cult it's like it's completely
unhinged and chaotic and improvised and
there's it's almost like people are just
it's as if the pagans even though they
were dealing with demons they they maybe
they had found a way to maybe like hold
the fire in a box or something they were
kind of had a way to tame it somehow
like not really but at least a little
bit but now it feels like people are
just with running around with matches in
the in in houses filled with explosives
and they're like oh look at this effect
look at what happens here oh this
actually works this blows up
like it's like they just have spiritual
experiences and they think that that's
enough to justify their behavior
right and you know the difference
between us now and ancient peoples with
their paganism
is you know ancient peoples were doing
this in community
right they saw that the worship of the
god bound them together the god became
part of their community they became part
of that god's community
right and they had notions of gods that
they worshipped that were supposedly
going to do good for the good things for
them and they also knew that they were
there were got you know gods who were
going to harm them and so they did
things to ward them off
right so
you're the modern person engaging with
these spirits does not have even that
pagan wisdom
no discernment zero discernment yeah
yeah it's individualistic because this
is this is through the blends of
modernism now so it's individualistic
it's it's my personal journey what's
happened is
this is paganism through the lens of
individualistic distorted christian
gospel
selling
right so it's it's now it instead of let
me tell you what jesus can do for your
life it's let me tell you what this
angel that i met you know through doing
drugs can do for your life
right so what we've done is we now have
this this reformation reduced gospel and
we're now using it in a pagan way
right and and so i mean it's just it's
utterly frightening and horrifying right
because because even even the community
kinds of safeguards that pagans put in
place
you know
that's not even there this is just
people in their in their own homes doing
these things separately
and um you know because we live in a
time where everything is contested and
contestable even where communities do
form of of neopagans and and or people
doing these doing drugs together and so
forth it's still all very fluid yeah
because they're not for instance bound
together by place
right you know most of these networks
exist on the internet um if they are
bound together by place there's almost
nothing preventing them from moving
somewhere else you know like
you know an ancient person did not tend
to move very often unless he was spurred
by necessity somehow yeah you know now
it's like oh well i i just want to move
to this place i'm going to move there or
or you know i got a job in another state
i'm going to go there and i'm going to
go to another country um so all of the
all of the kind of limitations that the
ancient world provided people
are no longer there and so it's just
this utter explosion
of spiritual engagements and um
it's very a lot of it is very very
dangerous very very dangerous and he
gives you insight into the flood like it
it gives you insight into how
this type of behavior and these types of
practices can lead to such a
fragmentation you know or the tower of
babel like you know where everybody ends
up it's even worse than the tower of
babel it's like every individual just
ends up speaking their own idiosyncratic
spiritual language and there's no
relationship between anybody else i mean
this is what it says in scripture every
man did what was right in his own eyes
yeah exactly i mean that that's like
that you know in the modern world that's
not a bug that's a feature
but it really is a bug
you know that's that's what it's that is
the damning thing that is said about the
immediate pre-flood civilization every
man did what was right in his own eyes
yeah it's amazing yeah it's amazing to
realize just how
just how much it's it's like what we're
going through now gives us insight into
what is in the scripture and vice versa
but it's not necessarily pleasant to
have that insight it's actually quite
frightening to kind of feel on the edge
of the precipice and to to see kind of
everything toppling over right and and
you know there is even a distorted
version of this that's hitting
christianity too
right because so christianity is a
universal message and call
it's absolutely universal it involves
nothing less than the whole cosmos yeah
right but now there is also this idea of
well i should have my
version of christianity maybe my
nationalistic version maybe my
ideological version my whatever version
right and and i'll have my little sect
and you know the more positive versions
of that just say well this is this is
for these people who live in this place
you know
we're going to keep those other people
at arm's length but this is you know and
but then the the dark version where it
inevitably goes it becomes about
conflict
and it becomes about
conquest this is literally the narrative
of paganism playing out under christian
guys
you know the the these sort of
nationalisms and um all of this is a
very you know identitarianism of every
kind
whether it's interesting to see whatever
that there that like you said they're
versions of it on both sides of the
political spectrum right there's there's
the kind of weird nationalism and this
this holding on to these these national
identities versus others and then then
there's the
the kind of consumer version of that
where i want i shop around for a church
that meets my needs and you know
whatever has the best like uh the the
best babysitting there's like that's the
church i'm gonna go to like whichever
church fills my needs the most is the
one and so you have virgins both on the
right and the left you could say of
these types so and and one there where
it's like i'm going to go to church that
everybody agrees with me politically
that everybody agrees with my ideology
uh it's just some general phenomena of
this kind of this breakdown yeah and you
know you can see so the opposite of that
is the way that for instance the
orthodox church talks about saints of
particular places
right now some people see that and say
oh look at these
russian orthodox saints or these greek
or whatever whatever adjective you want
to put on but actually the way that the
church talks about scenes in particular
places it says the saints who have shown
forth in this land
right it's not that they are
that that land defines them
because they belong to the heavenly
hosts who are
a cosmic reality yeah so it's closer to
the idea of the universal history as
we're presenting it it's like it's
actually a way for these particular
places to kind of be joined up into the
story of christ and into the life and
body right and you know and that's what
gives those places there in their
particular beauty right it's only as
they refer to the cosmic narrative that
they actually can shine forth
when it becomes when the gaze gets
turned back down towards created things
that's when it becomes idolatrous that's
when it becomes essentially pagan
you know any kind of anything that draws
a spiritual border between me and
another person it becomes a dark
distorted thing that actually doesn't
have anything to do with christ but when
we were both looking to christ then our
then our particulars shine forth in
their specific beautiful way
exactly and that's really the the whole
cosmic mystery that see in saint maximus
you know that's what we see in all these
these saints that show us how
multiplicity you know when it's turned
towards god when it's turned towards
christ and it starts to to shine but
when it turns towards itself just like
when adam took the apple you know just
all the sins of pride that we see in the
in the bible then you sink down in the
mire and you you know you lose that that
that that brightness yeah you know the
the
it's it's hard because like we we this
problem of the universal in particular
has always been sort of with us right
and
and a lot of times when people see
totalitarian approaches to things right
then then they resist the idea of any
kind of universal
but the problem with the totalitarianism
is not that it's universal it's that
it's universal in the wrong way yeah
right it's about universal power or
something like that or you know making
everyone think exactly the same but but
christianity is truly universal and the
way that it's universal brings out the
light of everyone that's within it yeah
you know um that's that's hard for us
you know because
uh like we hear the call of the
universal call to for instance to love
all of mankind and that can then take us
we can become totalitarian if we don't
refer that to god
you know but but if we we react against
that which i think is you know reacting
against totalitarianism is a totally
normal and utterly appropriate thing to
do
um but the we the way we need to react
against it is not to say i'm gonna draw
my little
fortress here and and i'm gonna invite
the people i want into it and everyone
else is not welcome
um you know what however they want to
define that the right way is to say you
know what
the kingdom of god is the kingdom
you know and in my father's house there
are many mansions
right that's that's the way that it
actually works it's only with that king
that you can actually have a universal
society
you know it's not no other king will
suffice you know and and any other king
that exists needs to refer his throne
back to the throne of god or else it's
going to become a very dark
and and distorting kind of kingdom
yeah yeah and it's it's a warning to all
of us to not
draw our
to not draw our life from politics you
know and to not not discount it it's
important it exists we have to deal with
it but to not feel like that this is
where our life comes from because it's
not yeah all that stuff has to be
relative to the kingdom of god yeah yeah
well father i think this is a great it's
a great place to end you know this is a
i think that this call is is right and
everybody
get you know get the book let god arise
it's just came out it's fresh off the of
the presses and uh we'll definitely
check in with father andrew again you
know as he kind of discovers this the
the mythological worldview more and more
we'll definitely find places to uh to
connect again so thank you father andrew
thank you very much